eine besondere ausgabe von die richtigen
fragen hier aus salzburg in österreich
wir treffen österreichs bundeskanzler
sebastian kurz und möchten mit ihm über
die großen krisen europas sprechen was
ist mit corona warum gibt es hier keine
masten pflicht mehr in österreich und in
deutschland doch was ist mit afghanistan
können wir noch abschieben dort wo die
taliban im vormarsch sind und umwelt wie
viel verzicht braucht es um das klima zu
retten
[Musik]
und jetzt ist auch schon bei uns
bundeskanzler sebastian kurz schönen
guten tag vielen dank für die entladung
er kurz ich war in den vergangenen
wochen in afghanistan und als ich zurück
geflogen bin hier nach europa da habe
ich mich gefragt wann wird die politik
sehen was dort passiert und hat mich an
2015 erinnert wann wussten sie 2015 dass
die flüchtlingskrise losgeht wir haben
sehr früh damals die ersten anzeichen
bemerkt als die migrationsströme mehr
geworden sind
die schlepper kriminalität zugenommen
hat da war eigentlich schon im frühling
klar da kommt etwas auf uns zu also
deutlich bevor es in den medien zum
beispiel das große thema war damals
wollten es viele in der politik noch
lange nicht wahrhaben und ich habe
durchaus die sorge dass vielleicht nicht
selbiges droht wie 2015 aber dass auch
jetzt die migrationsströme wieder
zunehmen und insofern müssen wir auch
als europäische union jetzt schon im
sommer aktiv werden um zu verhindern
dass es wieder ähnliche zustände gibt
wie damals ich will noch mal zeigen was
im passamt in kabul los war als ich dort
diese woche die menschen besucht habe
hier sehen wir die bilder tausende
kann die dort einen pass haben wollen
nicht habe sie dort besucht und mit
ihnen gesprochen viele von ihnen haben
mir gesagt sie wollen nach deutschland
sie wollen nach europa aus angst dort
eben vor den taliban hier sehen wir
einen derjenigen der dort die pässe
ausstellt abgestempelt viele viele
dokumente herr kurz wenn sie das sehen
haben sie dort panik wenn man das sieht
dann weiß man dass da massive probleme
auf uns zukommen können und ich glaube
es ist wichtig nicht dieselben fehler
wie 2015 zu machen die probleme
afghanistans wird man nicht durch die
unbeschränkte aufnahme in europa lösen
können
die probleme afghanistans kann man nur
vor ort lösen
jetzt sind wir als kleines militärisch
nicht sonderlich stark ist und neutrales
land die falschen um hier ratschläge zu
geben aber so wie viele waffen viele
dass der westen dort abgezogen dass die
us-truppen europa weil sie sagen man
kann die probleme vor ort lösen aber ich
war dort bei den menschen die haben
gesagt ihr lasst uns alleine hier sagt
sie wir sind ein kleines land haben aber
sie haben ja auch europa haben haben
militärisch nicht dieselben
möglichkeiten wie große supermächte und
daher glaube ich ist es falsch
ratschläge zu geben aber natürlich ganz
persönlich mache ich mir sorgen dass die
truppen abgezogen sind und haben
natürlich auch das gefühl dass das sehr
schnell dazu führen kann dass die
taliban die ja weite teile des
territoriums jetzt schon unter kontrolle
haben auch noch größere teile auch kabul
einnehmen können und das ist natürlich
alles andere als eine entwicklung die
unproblematisch ist das ist dramatisch
für die menschen dort
das wird zur migrationsströmen führen da
ist aber unser zugang dass die menschen
in der region versorgt werden müssen
wenn flucht notwendig ist dann ist der
sichere hafen in der region und wo ist
das dann aus ihrer sicht iran türkei
dann sollen die männer bleiben
na ja es ist natürlich so dass das
asylrecht immer so gedacht war als
individualrecht wenn jemand politisch
oder aus religiösen gründen verfolgt
wurde
das individualrecht hatte anderswo um
asyl an
zu suchen es war nie so gedacht das
ganze länder oder regionen sich auf den
weg machen sich dann in europa ein land
aussuchen und sagen ich möchte genau
nach deutschland das war nie im sinn
aber was machen wir wenn die menschen
dann in griechenland sind wie 2015 also
sie können jetzt sagen es wäre wichtig
dass sie in drittstaaten gehen aber die
menschen die ich dort getroffen habe sie
sagen sie wollen nach europa und zahlen
viel geld darin jemanden nach
griechenland illegal mit einem schlepper
durchgekommen ist dann haben wir schon
ein großes problem
daher bin ich auch sehr froh dass
mittlerweile die linie in europa sich
geändert hat der zugang ist anders als
2015 was sie dir auch in deutschland von
der kanzlerin merkel abwärts sagt jetzt
keiner mehr bitte macht euch auf den weg
er findet sicherheit in deutschland
sondern die signale sind genau
gegenteilig und das ist gut so und das
bedeutet auch dass länder an der
außengrenze wie italien wie griechenland
wie bulgarien ganz anders agieren als im
jahr 2015
das heißt um nur in einem satz noch
einmal zusammenzufassen was wir denken
wir glauben dass es notwendig ist vor
ort zu helfen
da ist das militärische das eine es gibt
auch die möglichkeit humanitär zu helfen
das versuchen wir als republik
österreich überproportional und ganz
intensiv in afghanistan und anderen
ländern der region
aber der weg nach europa das kann nicht
die lösung des problems in afghanistan
sagt sie sprechen kanzlerin merkel an
2015 gestern hat sie sich äußert sich in
dieser woche geäußert
zum thema flüchtlinge und afghanistan
aber es gibt auch sehr bittere
erfahrungen und so wie sie es in
afghanistan gibt gibt es sie auch leider
in anderen ländern der erde und nicht
alle diese probleme können dadurch lösen
dass wir die menschen aufnehmen wenn sie
das hören von der kanzlerin hat gott sei
dank ich halte das für den absolut
richtigen zugang
ich glaube es hat sich mittlerweile ja
überall herumgesprochen dass diese
massiven migrationsbewegungen von
menschen aus ganz anderen kulturkreisen
die teilweise schlecht oder gar nicht
ausgebildet sind dass die zu massiven
problemen in europa geführt haben
schauen sie sich an die
sicherheitssituation
in einigen französischen vorstädten was
wir in belgien und anderen ländern immer
wieder erleben mussten
und auch in österreich wir haben vor
kurzer zeit die situation gehabt dass
mehrere afghanische junge männer ein 13
jähriges mädchen unter drogen gesetzt
vergewaltigt ermordet und dann wie eine
sache abgelegt haben
das ist einfach eine barbarische das ist
nicht in worte zu fassen das was hier
teilweise stattfindet man darf nicht den
fehler machen dann alle über einen kamm
zu scheren und zu verallgemeinern aber
es stimmt dass wir mit vielen die aus
afghanistan aus tschetschenien und
anderen teilen der welt gekommen sind
aus ganz anderen systemen aus ganz
anderen kulturkreisen dass es hier
massive probleme gibt es das eine neue
qualität der gewalt kriminalität die da
er selbstverständlich ja
selbstverständlich
sie müssen sich ja nur die in der die
kriminalitätsstatistiken anschauen
vieles was es hier an brutalität gibt
hat es in der vergangenheit so nicht
gegeben
die zahlen sie noch sehr eindeutig in
gewissen gruppen was was die häufung der
gewaltverbrechen betrifft was die
häufung von sexueller gewalt gegen
frauen zum beispiel betrifft
das ist etwas das darf man nicht
schönreden ich bin jemand der das klar
auch ausspricht und genauso wie über
nicht verallgemeinern sollte genauso
muss man solche probleme einfach
bekämpfen und da gibt es viel was wir in
unseren staaten machen müssen aber ganz
wesentlich ist auch keine unbeschränkte
migration nach europa nach österreich
und in andere länder aber ich habe immer
noch nicht so ganz verstanden was ich
seit 2005 10 verändert hat aus ihrer
sicht sind zum einen was die kanzlerin
dort gesagt hat wahrscheinlich sind sie
überrascht dass das erste mal dass sie
jetzt etwas unterschreiben können was
die kanzlerin flüchtigen seiten und
gleichzeitig ist es aber so dass er der
weg richtung griechenland weiterhin
offen es hat sich es hat sich ganz viel
geändert wenn ich an 2015 zurückblicke
dann war die haltung der masse der
regierungschefs in europa die grenzen
sind offen wir helfen
und refugees welt kann das war die
haltung im jahr 2015 und sie wissen das
ja besser als die meisten anderen wie
vernetzt die welt ist und dass auch in
diesen teilen der welt viele menschen
ein mobiltelefon besitzen genau
mitverfolgen welche politischen
botschaften ist auch in europa was
machen die das aber so machen sind dass
man die wende wenn es wieder so
ich wollte aus rein natürlichen und
wollte geradeaus während der erste punkt
ist einmal die signale aus europa sind
ganz andere als damals das ist wichtig
weil diese signale kommen beim empfänger
also man möchte den flüchtlingen klar
machen sie sind nicht willkommen oder
wie man muss den menschen klar machen
dass sie sich nicht auf den weg nach
europa machen
wie funktioniert das ist naja die
kanzlerin hat ja schon ganz anders
kommuniziert zum beispiel dass im jahr
2015 also allein das löst etwas aus
zweiter punkt wir haben eine andere
situation gott sei dank mittlerweile in
der türkei und entlang der länder
griechenland und am westbalkan damals
ist weiter gefunden worden ich erinnere
daran dass damals europäische gelder
dafür verwendet worden sind die
flüchtlinge oder die migranten von einer
grenze an die nächste zu führen bis sie
dann in deutschland angekommen sind
es ist di di di di di die route der
schlepper finanziell aus brüssel auch
noch unterstützt worden
jetzt versuchen sie dann einmal eher
interessiert das gegenteil muss ihnen
einmal widersprechen ich glaube nicht
dass diejenigen die von den taliban
verfolgt werden sich von diesen worten
der kanzlerin oder von ihnen nachher
lassen möchten einmal zeigen was ich tun
wollte innerhalb aber da wir sind ganz
kurz ausführen weil ich glaube es wäre
verkehrt zu sagen es geht nur um die
worte das ist der erste punkt nicht
erwähnt habe der zweite ist das geld das
damals investiert wurde um die menschen
weiter zu transportieren wird heute da
investiert um sie zu stoppen
das heißt es wird wesentlich mehr ein
frontex investiert es gibt ein abkommen
mit der türkei
dass die menschen nicht nach europa
durchgelassen werden
die griechische regierung ist heute eine
andere als damals und agiert wesentlich
robuster schon im mittelmeer und
versucht zu verhindern dass schlepper
menschen nach griechenland bringen
brauchte das abschiebe plätze aus
fremden
zum beispiel selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich und heute das
passieren weil das wollten sie immer
haben sie aber nie hinbekommen müssen
wir hätten das gerne
es gab auf europäischer ebene noch immer
kein klares commitment dazu aber das
thema rückführung ist er wieder ein
eigenes aber um das zu besprechen ich
glaube dass zwei punkte her wichtig
wären erstens möglichkeiten über
drittstaaten abzuschieben das heißt dass
wir in einer abschiebung in das
herkunftsland direkt nicht funktioniert
dass man über drittstaaten abschied wäre
das dann bei afghanistan bei den
aufgaben die zum beispiel nach
griechenland geben wollen wollen sie die
abschied
na ja das geht ja nicht darum dass die
alle nachhinein kommen gibt es genug die
jetzt schon illegal da sind die
natürlich auch abgeschoben werden wo
sind in welche länder den sie aus
afghanistan kommen auch nachher
afghanistan da möchte ich ihnen einmal
so wir haben uns viele afghanen zum
beispiel die aus dem iran oder anderen
ländern kommen
aber ich möchte ihnen einmal jemand der
dort mehrere wochen waren weiß so aber
seine haltung nicht verändern
dennoch möchte ich ihnen etwas zeigen
was ich dort mit einem richter der
taliban erlebt
was man hat mich ja aber
wollen sie ernsthaft afghanen die vor so
einem taliban richter fliehen sagen
bleibt doch in eurem land oder das ist
okay euch da wieder hin in ramschied
aber ich möchte genau diese kranke
ideologie nicht nach europa importieren
und ich sage ihnen was herum zwei mal
wenn ich mir anschaue welche
herausforderungen wir mittlerweile mit
menschen haben die im jahr 2015 und
folgende gekommen sind dann kann ich
ihnen nur sagen es gibt gott sei dank
viele die sich gut integrieren
aber wir haben sehr sehr viele menschen
auch in europa die genau dieses
gedankengut nach europa bringen sie
sprechen aber wenig über diejenigen die
sich gut integriert haben
wir sprechen viel über die die sich gut
integriert haben wir haben uns summen an
geld in die hand genommen
für deutschkurse für werte schulungen
für integrationsprogramme im
arbeitsmarkt und wir sind bei jedem
einzelnen froh der sich gut integriert
aber ich bin einfach niemand die
probleme leugnet und wir haben gerade
durch diese migrationsströme in den
letzten jahren sehr viel an
antisemitismus nach europa importiert
wir haben viele menschen die zu uns
gekommen sind die klar homophob sind
oder die mit den rechten der frau ist
nicht unbedingt hoch halten und wir
haben aber das ist mit unserer
moralischen verpflichtungen den menschen
gegenüber die ich dort getroffen habe
was ist mit den frauen die jetzt angst
haben dass die taliban sie einsperren
was ist mit menschen die angst haben
davor dass ihnen die finger abgehackt
werden die taliban die ich dort
getroffen aber die haben mir erzählt sie
wollen bis kaprun sie wollen dort in das
stadion und wieder hinrichtung durch
schön und sie sagen kein problem und
arbeiter in den abschieben nein aber ich
bin dafür dass man bei den fakten bleibt
die taliban und das wissen sie haben
jetzt schon jetzt schon den großteil des
gebiets in afghanistan kontrolliert noch
nicht kabul noch nicht gewisse teile des
landes aber auch bevor die truppen
abgezogen sind haben die taliban weite
teile afghanistans kontrolliert auch
oftmals von der bevölkerung geduldet
sicherlich auch von manchen teilen der
bevölkerung unterstützt
das ist einfach eine wahrheit die man
aussprechen muss aber bedeutende werden
sie werden egal was kommt weiterhin nach
afghanistan abschieden genfer
flüchtlingskonvention alles was passiert
egal was in afghanistan passiert sie
schieben weiter haben wir werden
sicherlich weiter nach afghanistan
abschieben und ich bin der meinung dass
wir die probleme afghanistans nicht
dadurch lösen können dass deutschland
und österreich sowie im jahr 2015
massenhaft menschen aufnimmt sondern
muss uns wichtig erscheint ist die
situation vor ort zu verbessern
ich bin genau so kritisch wie sie was
den truppenabzug betrieb weil wir haben
menschen doch dort allein gelassen
fühlen sich verlassen
sie sagen wir sollen den menschen helfen
die internationalen truppen sind weg und
sie sagen aber abschieben geht jetzt
trotzdem weiter das passt doch nicht
zusammen naja ich war gerade in den usa
und habe eine lange diskussion geführt
mit vielen vertretern auch aus den usa
zur frage truppenabzug und da gibt es
sehr unterschiedliche meinungen es gibt
diejenigen die sagen das ist er auch die
these der ich angehöre die situation
kann jetzt noch deutlich schlechter
werden weil die truppen abgezogen sind
und es gibt andere die sagen wir sind
schon viel zu lange dort und haben es
nicht geschafft die situation massiv zu
stabilisieren oder zu verbessern beiden
thesen kann man etwas abgewinnen
und nochmal zurück ein weiterer teil des
landes war jetzt schon von den taliban
kontrolliert ich hoffe sehr dass nicht
kabul und der rest des landes auch noch
unter die kontrolle der taliban feld ich
hoffe sehr dass es weiterhin
unterstützung für die afghanische armee
gibt für die regierung gibt um auch
selbst gegen die taliban zu kämpfen und
wir stehen selbstverständlich für
humanitäre hilfe in afghanistan und den
ländern der region bereit aber bei allem
respekt wenn menschen fliehen müssen
dann halte ich die nachbarstaaten wie
die türkei oder andere sichere teile
afghanistans definitiv für den richtigen
ort als dass die menschen alle nach
österreich deutschland oder schweden
gekommen
ich bin sicher das thema afghanistan
wird uns in diesen wochen und monaten
weiter intensiv beschäftigen und
insbesondere einige regierungschefs
glaube ich werde noch davon überrascht
sein wie viele menschen so hab ich
zumindest in afghanistan überlebt er
lebt nach europa kommen werden ein
weiteres großes thema und für die
menschen wichtig das thema corona her
kurz
wir sitzen hier in österreich und die
masten pflicht ist fast
komplett gefallen obwohl die instanz
weit über der in deutschland liegt wie
funktioniert das also zunächst einmal
würde ich gerne festhalten dass wir
ungefähr zehnmal so viele tests
durchführen wie in deutschland
ja wir haben steigende ansteckungszahlen
aber wir sind genauso wie deutschland
unter den ländern mit unter den besten
drittel in der europäischen union würde
ich sagen also was niedrige
ansteckungszahlen betrifft in unserem
fall sind wir aber auch noch
europameister im testen das heißt ich
behaupte mal dass wir die niedrigste
dunkelziffer haben von allen
europäischen ländern
und ich glaube so zu sagen was wir alle
erlernen müssen ist mit dem virus zu
leben wir haben durch die impfung den
game changer wer sich impfen lässt der
ist geschützt anders formuliert wer sich
nicht impfen lässt der kann sich
natürlich anstecken und der wird sich
auch irgendwann an stellten dann die in
eigene schuld sozusagen der person die
sich jetzt nicht impfen es geht nicht um
eine schuldfrage sondern es geht darum
einfach klar auszusprechen was sache ist
wir haben eineinhalb jahre lang mit
massiven einschränkungen der grund- und
freiheitsrechte versucht alles zu tun um
die ansteckungszahlen so niedrig wie
möglich zu halten wir haben einen
massiven wirtschaftlichen schaden
dadurch angerichtet viele menschen haben
ihren job verloren
in familien war die situation extrem
schwierig kinder haben darunter gelitten
dass sie nicht in die schule gehen
konnten also all das sollten wir nicht
vergessen das war ja gerade alles noch
unmittelbar da und ich glaube auch für
politisch verantwortliche sichtbar dass
das ein problem ist warum haben wir das
getan weil wir gewusst haben wir können
es schaffen bis zur impfung wir können
sozusagen die situation unter kontrolle
behalten und mit der impfung gibt es
dann den game changer mittlerweile sind
in österreich von neun millionen
einwohner und 5,2 millionen menschen
geimpft das heißt über oder fast 90
prozent der 65 plus generation ist
geimpft
und das bedeutet nicht dass sich niemand
mehr an steckt natürlich stecken sich
die menschen an ist ja klar wenn das
leben wieder stattfindet aber das
bedeutet nicht dass automatisch die
hospitalisierungen im
selben ausmaß hinauf schnellen also die
intelligenz auch die institute schauen
sie nicht
natürlich schaue ich auf die inzidenz
aber ich schaue nicht nur auf die
inzidenz und ich würde da hingehen
tabell ihren dass wir in ganz europa das
vollziehen was eigentlich von der
wissenschaft und von vielen seiten schon
lange empfohlen wird nämlich bei dem zu
bleiben was immer relevant war nämlich
die belegung in den spitälern also
vitalisierung des wichtiger als instanz
aus ihrer selbst mittlerweile warum
haben wir so entschlossen gegen korona
angekämpft um zu verhindern dass es eine
überlastung der intensivstationen gibt
wir haben ja nicht ein problem damit
gehabt wenn sich wer angesteckt hat und
der jetzt nicht mal gemerkt und er war
sozusagen zwar messbar aber de facto hat
es nur der test mitbekommen und er
selbst hat nichts von seiner ansteckung
mitbekommen aber dennoch es war ja nie
unser problem unser problem war immer
die sorge der überlastung der
intensivstationen ich bin stolz dass wir
in österreich die situation immer unter
kontrolle hatten dass es nie zu einer
überlastung gekommen ist dass wir auch
im europäischen vergleich sowie in
deutschland die todeszahlen niedriger
halten konnten als im finale was ich
eben menschen in deutschland fragen kurz
ich möchte einmal ein foto zeigen von
ihnen und dem bundespräsidenten in
bregenz bei einer veranstaltung
das sieht man etwas was wir uns in
deutschland ja kaum vorstellen können
viele menschen zusammen ohne maske aber
frag ich mich kurz übertreiben wir in
deutschland oder sind sie leichtsinnig
ich glaube sie können sich oft in
deutschland etwas nicht vorstellen was
sind ein paar wochen später in
deutschland einfach machen und auf
einmal ist für sie ganz normal und das
wird auch in deutschland passieren im
herbst auch noch nicht mal schauen aber
ich habe den eindruck so zu sagen das
natürlich aus deutscher sicht immer das
was deutschland tut die absolute norm
ist und man wundert sich über alle
anderen die sich nicht eins zu eins
gleich verhalten wie in deutschland ich
kann ihnen sagen wir haben in österreich
die schulen zum beispiel deutlich früher
geöffnet als in deutschland
und was haben wir getan wir haben
dreimal die woche die kinder getestet
und es hat funktioniert
wir haben in weiten teilen österreichs
sind es eine schul versprechen von ihnen
bleibt in jedem fall im neuen schuljahr
bleiben die schulen offen definitiv
selbstverständlich wir werden die selbe
strategie fahren wie in der dritten
welle die hat gut funktioniert
intensives testen sicherheitsstandards
überall dort wo es notwendig ist und der
versuch ansteckungen zu vermeiden
aber wir können ja jetzt nicht auf dauer
die schulen geschlossen halten und ich
möchte einen gedanken mit ihnen nur zu
ende denken herrnsheimer ich habe das
gefühl manche sagen jetzt ein paar
wochen noch die masken oder ein paar
wochen noch ein bisschen schärfere
maßnahmen
und dann ist es ja überstanden wissen
sie was die traurige wahrheit ist dass
corona virus das wird nicht in ein paar
wochen verschwinden
das ist in einem jahr noch da das ist in
drei jahren noch da das ist in fünf
jahren noch da wenn wir keinen weg
finden trotz corona die schulen zu
öffnen
dann sollten wir den eltern auch klar
sagen dass wir die nächsten fünf jahre
nicht mehr öffnen werden können sich
erklärt warum einige experten das aber
so sehen und dann hingegen über vorwürfe
zum beispiel machen und sagen na ja sie
sind dann bei der zweiten welle haben
sie zu spät reagiert jetzt machen sie
wieder alles zu früh wie gehen sie mit
diesen vorwürfen um
ich werde als bundeskanzler ständig von
allen seiten kritisiert es gibt
diejenigen die sagen wir sind so
leichtsinnig und gleichzeitig überall wo
ich hingehe gibt es demonstranten die
gegen die krone maßnahmen zu
protestieren
das ist normal in einer liberalen
demokratie und dann fallen alle marko
marin ein ziemlich kurz mal ausreden und
der diskurs ist ja auch in ordnung
unser zugang ist nicht leichtsinnig zu
sein sondern wenn es steigende zahlen
gibt wenn es probleme gibt dann werden
wir sofort darauf reagieren
aber wir betrachten nicht nur die
ansteckungszahlen sondern wir betrachten
vor allem auch die situation in den
spitälern
es macht einen großen unterschied ob
sich ältere menschen infizieren oder ob
sich junge menschen infizieren in
österreich finden derzeit 70 der
ansteckungen bei der generation 35 und
jünger statt und 5 prozent der
ansteckungen bei der generation 65 und
älter
die impfung wirkt wir haben die
situation dass auch wenn die
ansteckungszahlen steigen werden klar
wird auch in den spitälern wieder mehr
bedarf an behandlung geben aber nicht
eine so schnelle vision virtuelle
hercules was glauben sie da gibt es
große diskussionen weltweit wir sehen
zum beispiel in israel große sorge aus
britannien wie wird die peter seiler
virus wird nicht verschwinden aber es
ist ganz einfach wer sich impfen lässt
der ist geschützt wer sich nicht impfen
lässt der wird sich früher oder später
anstecken
wir können natürlich die sicherheit der
ansatz immer noch ein stück höher
lassen wir können die schulen zu lassen
im herbst wir können auf
großveranstaltungen verzichten
wir könnten auch sagen die leute sollen
im sommer nicht auf urlaub fahren lassen
wir es doch noch ein paar monate so wie
es war
wir können auch noch einen lock down
verhängen all das würde dazu führen dass
die ansteckungszahlen niedriger bleiben
das löst aber extreme kollateralschäden
aus das führt dazu dass menschen ihren
arbeitsplatz verlieren
das führt dazu dass familien über
schnappen weil sie homeschooling und job
nicht mehr unter einen hut bringen
können das führt auch dazu dass mehr und
mehr menschen psychische probleme
bekommen weil ihn dann einfach der
kontakt mit anderen oder das leben ab
geht und daher bin ich der meinung die
impfung ist hundertmal besser als der
lok dann unser ziel in österreich ist
das also möglichst viele menschen dazu
zu bewegen sich impfen zu lassen und
allen die sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen einfach reinen wein einzuschenken
und ihnen ehrlich zu sagen du wirst dich
früher oder später anstecken wenn du
dich nicht impfen lässt dann wirst du
dich irgendwann anstecken wenn nicht im
sommer dann im herbst und wenn ich dem
herbst dann im winter aber man wird
niemanden der sich nicht impfen lässt
dauerhaft vor einer ansteckung schützen
können
sie sprechen den lock down under zu den
maßnahmen und dem vergleich zu
deutschland
ich glaube nicht dass wir locker
ich glaube nur dass wir teilweise andere
regeln das will ich nicht bewerten aber
wir waren eines der ersten länder
weltweit das auf intensives testen
gesetzt hat wir haben die 3g regel
eingeführt das heißt bei einer
großveranstaltung gibt es nur einlass
wenn man geimpft getestet oder genesen
ist und jetzt kann man darüber
diskutieren was sicherer ist die
dreijährige oder die maske ich habe die
erfahrung gemacht dass die maske von
vielen menschen zwar brav getragen wird
wenn sie keinen kontakt zu anderen haben
aber und alleine auf ihrem platz sitzen
aber sobald sie auf der toilette sind
und ein stau ist wird die maske
abgenommen sobald sie wind begrüßen
wollen wird die maske abgenommen sie
begrüßen wieder mit handschlag oder ist
glaube ich so eine zwischenphase wo man
oft nicht genau weiß wie man jetzt soll
aber ich bin zweimal geimpft ich lasse
mich regelmäßig testen und versuche
damit meinen beitrag zu leisten an warum
sie oft vor und geben wieder die hand
haben wenn mir jemand die hand hin
streckt dann gebe ich sie ihm auch und
ich bin ehrlich gesagt froh dass das
soziale miteinander auch wieder
stattfindet ich habe sehr darunter
gelitten den menschen grund und
freiheitsrechte einschränken zu müssen
ich habe das getan wir haben als
österreich früher einen lockt dann
eingeführt als deutschland zum beispiel
wir haben oft sehr schnell und sehr
konsequent reagiert aber diese maßnahmen
dürfen nie zum selbstzweck werden das
darf immer nur die ultima ratio sein
wenn über schnelligkeit und konsequenz
sprechen herr kurz kommen wir zu dritten
wichtigen themenkomplex den der die
menschen beschäftigt besonders in
deutschland und sicherlich auch hier in
österreich der frage was mit dem klima
passiert wir haben eine flut katastrophe
erlebt in deutschland noch schlimmer als
in österreich
diese flut aus ihrer sicht etwas mit dem
klimawandel zu tun oder war es vor allem
ein versagen des katastrophenschutzes
krebs fragen kann man oft nicht so
einseitig beantworten
zunächst einmal würde ich ungern da
jetzt katastrophenschutz
verantwortlichen vorwürfe machen ich
kann nur für österreich sprechen
wir haben gott sei dank keine todesopfer
gehabt wir haben bei
unwetter katastrophe gesehen dass viele
maßnahmen die wir in den letzten jahren
und jahrzehnten gesetzt haben gewirkt
haben dass die schäden noch viel größer
hätten sein können
und wir haben gesehen dass andere
projekte die in planung sind schnell
umgesetzt werden sollten weil wir dann
beim nächsten mal noch besser geschützt
sein werden
und ja natürlich haben wir es generell
damit zu tun dass es so scheint als
würden unwetterkatastrophen und anderes
immer stärker und intensiver werden
dem klimawandel zu tun als ihr glaube
schon dass das mit dem klimawandel zu
tun hat und ich glaube vor allem das
unabhängig von der debatte über
naturkatastrophen und unwetter dass es
generell einfach ganz klar ist dass wir
gegen die erderwärmung ankämpfen müssen
dazu dort sagen sie zum beispiel jetzt
in diesen tagen haben sie davor gewarnt
dass der klimaschutz ein weg zurück in
die steinzeit
da haben sie mich falsch zitiert meinen
sie damit ich habe gesagt dass der
klimaschutz durch innovation und
fortschritt funktionieren muss und nicht
durch verzicht und einen weg zurück in
die steinzeit was meine ich damit ich
habe jetzt die ersten vernommen die
gesagt haben die lok downs haben gegen
die pandemie so gut gewirkt jetzt
braucht klima lockt downs also sozusagen
ein herunterfahren des öffentlichen
lebens der gesellschaft weniger
mobilität weniger reisetätigkeit all das
damit wir das klima retten und daran
glaube ich nicht ich glaube nicht dass
klimaschutz durch verzicht funktioniert
sondern hat viele wissenschaftler sagen
da sie haben heute auch widersprochen
und gesagt doch es braucht es gibt eine
breite diskussion in der wissenschaft
und das ist ja gut so und es gibt eine
breite debatte in der politik meine
position ist klar nämlich ein
ambitionierter kampf gegen den
klimawandel
wir haben in österreich zum beispiel
mittlerweile 70 prozent strom aus
erneuerbarer energie
wir werden 2030 100 strom aus
erneuerbarer energie haben wir sind
damit unter den weltbesten
wir investieren gerade massiv in den
ausbau des öffentlichen verkehrs wir
investieren massiv in gebäudesanierung
der kesseltausch also ich glaube das ist
viele maßnahmen gibt die sinn macht aber
die europäische union
entschuldigen sie dass sie unterbrechen
kurz die will ja schon verzicht wir
schauen uns mal an hat ein riesiges
paket für den klimaschutz vorgelegt fit
for fire fighters und danach soll der
co2 ausstoß um 55 prozent im vergleich
zu 1990 bereits 20 30 statt 20 40
erreicht werden wir selbstverständlich
das bedeutet aber ja benzin diesel gas
öl das wird alles teurer an das ist dann
ja auch verzicht aber darf ich darf ich
ganz kurz nur widersprechen es ist ja
nicht die frage ob wir leben und ob wir
uns fortbewegen und ob wir mobil sind
sondern es ist die frage wie viel
emissionen stehen dabei natürlich kann
man sagen es ist wichtig im sinne des
klimawandels dass wir im winter nicht
mehr heizen und alle zuhause frieren und
bei 16 grad kann man auch überleben es
ist nicht notwendig dass es in den
wohnungen 22 grad und erhielt dafür den
preis ja man kann es auch so teuer
machen dass sich die menschen nicht mehr
leisten können dann dann dann müssen sie
verzichten
ich glaube nicht dass es der richtige
weg ist den menschen zu sagen es ist gut
wenn ihr in der wohnung im winter friert
denn dadurch hättet ihr das klima
sondern ich bin fest davon überzeugt
dass es sinnvoll ist auf eine bessere
isolierung zu setzen moderner zu bauen
und den fortschritt zu nutzen den sie in
dem bereich gibt aber andere waren als
jahr in der eu und wenn wir uns jetzt
überlegen wir sind als entschuldigung
ich muss wirklich entschlossen
widerspreche ich kenne ganz ganz viele
in der europäischen union das wirklich
ernst meinen mit dem klimawandel und die
nicht sagen die leute sollen jetzt
verzichten sie sollen frieren in den
wohnungen es darum geht es ja nicht die
lage ist sozusagen
worum geht es genau um die frage es geht
um die frage glauben wir dass wir uns
einschränken müssen oder glauben wir an
den technologischen fortschritt an der
sagen wissenschaftler der
weiterentwicklung und andere sagen
gegenteiliges ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass die menschheit zu
unfassbaren imstande ist wenn sie will
wo ein wille den letzten 30 jahren ja
nicht und an letzten sowie ja es gab in
den letzten 50 jahren aber auch nicht
das notwendige bewusstsein in dem
bereich ich habe in der pandemie erlebt
dass durch globale zusammenarbeit der
wissenschaft innerhalb von einem jahr
ein impfstoff hergestellt worden ist das
hat früher ein jahrzehnt oder noch
länger gedauert
schauen wir uns an den enormen
fortschritt in der solarenergie zum
beispiel dass eine solarzelle für den
privaten häuslebauer vor zehn jahren
gekostet hat und was heute kostet
schauen wir uns an den fortschritt in
der elektromobilität vor zehn jahren war
vieles noch undenkbar
mittlerweile stellen mehr und mehr große
autobauer fast vollständig auf elektro
aber das bedeutet ja der plan der
eu-kommission für klimaneutralität geht
er am ende auf oder setzen wir da
sozusagen die falschen akzente und
müssen wir größer sein
ich glaube dass der plan absolut
funktionieren kann wir haben derzeit
einen großen teil der emissionen zum
beispiel im verkehr
das heißt wenn menschen die umsteigen
können
öffentliche verkehrsmittel nutzen und
wenn diejenigen dieses auto brauchen
hier immer co2 ärmere motoren verwenden
oder sogar auf elektromobilität und
steigen dann wird eine massive
veränderung geben und es wird möglich
sein die die co2 emissionen massiv zu
reduzieren was ich nur ablehne ist diese
debatte mit dem erhobenen zeigefinger
also kein wie was wieso schlagen denn
jemand wie soll denn jemand der im
ländlichen sie sind aus berlin wenn sie
nötig aus friesland wir ja aber sie
leben in berlin
da geht es natürlich ohne auto wenn sie
da in der nähe von salzburg in einer
kleinen ortschaft leben und sie haben
einen arbeitsplatz in salzburg hat dann
müssten sie selbstverständlich irgendwie
pendeln und selbst wenn sie nur bis zum
zug pendelt aber sie werden auf den
letzten metern ein auto brauchen das
wird anders niemals möglich sein und
diesen menschen zu sagen nutzt durch die
u-bahn
das halte ich für etwas überheblich er
kurz ganz schnell zum abschluss noch ein
paar persönliche fragen was ihre zukunft
betrifft
in deutschland hat die kanzlerin 16
jahre regiert jetzt in diesem sommer
vorbei sie sind 35 und mit unterbrechung
seit 20 18 bundeskanzler wollen sie auch
noch mit 40 kanzler sein
also ich habe ein mandat das vor zwei
jahren begonnen hat das noch drei jahre
dauert und ich fühle mich derzeit sehr
wohl in der politik glaubt dass ich an
beitrag leisten kann und so lange ich
dieses gefühl habe werde ich auch
versuchen einen beitrag zu leisten aber
alles schritt für schritt
jetzt gibt es die vorwürfe im
zusammenhang mit der staat soll den
ölberg und ihre aussage im
untersuchungsausschuss da stellen sich
viele die frage rechnen sie jetzt mit
der anlage wird die kommen das kann
gleich sein
ich gehe davon aus das habe ich immer
gesagt dass wenn sich werde die mühe
macht 460 seiten zu schreiben die mir
nicht immer nachvollziehbar sind
dann will er vielleicht alles versuchen
um anzuklagen
aber ich hab das mehrfach mittlerweile
durch gelesen und kann nur sagen ich
kann nach wie vor nach wie vor nicht
erkennen wo ich etwas falsches gesagt
hätte und selbst wenn etwas falsch
gewesen wäre dann wäre ich doch niemals
so dumm gewesen und hätte vorsätzlich
eine falsche aussage getätigt kann ein
angeklagter bundeskanzler bleibt wie er
selbstverständlich denn ich habe
mittlerweile mehrfach erlebt dass
menschen etwas falsches vorgeworfen wird
und dass sie schlicht und ergreifend
durch diese falschen vorwürfe medial
beschädigt werden sollen und am ende
stellt sich dann irgendwann heraus es
war nie etwas dran
das problem ist die berichterstattung
dazu die ist dann meistens winzig es hat
es hat gegen viele personen aus meiner
partei in den letzten jahren vorwürfe
gegeben
wissen sie was all diese vorwürfe
gemeinsam haben sind sich alle als
falsch herausgestellt aber wieder
anklagebank saßen die nicht als
kanzleramt nicht dass das ist schon
richtig aber ich weiß was ich in meinem
leben getan habe und ich weiß was ich
nicht getan habe und jeder macht den
gerichte geht er macht etwas falsch
aber ich habe definitiv immer
vorsätzlich die wahrheit gesagt und wenn
ich mir meine aussagen durchlese dann
kann ich nur sagen auch nach mehrmaligen
durchlesen
würde ich nicht herausfinden wo da etwas
falsches gewesen sein sollte haben sie
ihr kommunikationsverhalten whatsapp
verhalten verändern
ich kommuniziere genauso wie früher
und natürlich ist es so dass man im
persönlichen gespräch oder oder oder mal
in einer schnellen nachricht sich weil
über jemanden ärgert vielleicht einmal
eine andere wortwahl verwendet als man
sie verwenden sollte aber ich glaube es
ist schon wichtig zu unterscheiden was
ist eine flapsige formulierung was
bereut man vielleicht doch selbst oder
würde man nicht noch einmal so
formulieren
und was ist strafrechtlich relevant und
ein verbrechen
sie haben jungs per twitter bekannt
gegeben mehr kurz dass sie vater werden
wir sehen hier das foto was sie bei
twitter veröffentlicht haben
sie erwarten ein kind wenn sie jetzt
daran denken freuen sie sich auf die
rolle als papa und haben sie da als
kanzler überhaupt zeit dafür wenn sie
zum beispiel vaterschaftsurlaub nehmen
wenn es soweit ist
ich freue mich darauf ich bitte aber um
verständnis wir haben unser privatleben
bisher immer gern privat gehalten das
tun wir auch weiter so die
schwangerschaft lässt sich irgendwann
also sozusagen irgendwann wird das so
sichtbar dass es für alle offensichtlich
wird und haben das auch öffentlich
bekannt gegeben
aber das war's damit auch und mein
privatleben wird weiterhin privat
bleiben aber werden sie elternzeit
nehmen und österreich wissen sie das
schon habe ich darüber nachgedacht
ich werde diese fragen gern beizeiten
während worden
herzlichen dank bundeskanzler sebastian
kurz im interview bei die richtigen
fragen
das war es auch schon und alle weiteren
infos gibt es bei bitte danke
[Musik]